Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory black prince said to the king. Again, I pray you for a moment of patience. It is your word and only yours which can tell us what is just and right. To whom were you graciously pleased to commit your royal person? King John looked slowly around. There was a devil of a yellow horse,
谢谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告单集、系列节目抢先听，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory 黑太子对国王说：“再次恳求您稍等片刻。只有您的话，才最能告诉我们什么是公正与正确。您是凭着怎样的信任，才将您尊贵的王体交托出去的呢？”约翰国王缓缓环顾四周。这里有一匹要命的黄色战马，
said he. My poor Palfrey went over like a skittle-peen before a ball. Of the rider I know nothing, save that he bore red roses on a silver shield. Ah, by Saint-Denis! There is the man himself, and there his thrice-accursed horse. His head swimming and moving as if in a dream, Nigel found himself the centre of the circle of armed men. The black prince laid his hand upon his shoulder. It is the little cock of Tilford Bridge, said he. On my father's soul, I have ever said that you would win your way, and I had rather have the honour this squire has gathered than all the richest ransoms of France. At these words, spoken before that circle of noble warriors, Nigel's heart gave one great throb, and he dropped upon his knee before the prince. Fair lord, how can I thank you? he murmured. These words at least are more than any ransom. Rise up, said the smiling
他说：“我那可怜的帕尔弗雷（Palfry）战马就像打保龄球时被击倒的木柱一样倒了下去。至于骑士本人，我一无所知，只知道他的银盾上绘着红玫瑰。啊，圣德尼在上！那不就是他本人吗，还有他那匹该遭天谴的战马。”尼杰尔只觉得脑海中天旋地转，仿佛置身梦境，回过神时，自己已然成了这圈武装人员的中心。黑太子将一只手搭在他的肩上。“这就是蒂尔福德桥（Tilford Bridge）的那只小斗鸡，”他说，“凭着我父亲的灵魂，我一直说你会闯出一番名堂，相比法兰西最丰厚的赎金，我宁愿要这位年轻骑士所赢得的荣誉。”听到这番话——在这群尊贵的勇士环绕中说出，尼杰尔的心猛地跳动了一下，随后双膝跪倒在王子面前。“尊贵的阁下，我该如何感谢您？”他喃喃自语道，“至少这些话，比任何赎金都更为珍贵。”微笑着的王子说道：“站起来，
prince, and he smote with his sword upon his shoulder. England has lost a brave squire and has gained a gallant knight. Nay, linger not, I pray. Rise up, Sir Nigel. And that, Tom Holland, is the climactic scene of Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's masterwork, one of the books that he believed would be remembered long after Sherlock Holmes and Dr. Watson were forgotten, Sir Nigel, the which we ended last time. The flower of French chivalry cut down like dogs. The Black Prince triumphant. Nigel having captured King Jean II of France, who, as we heard last time, led in... Actually, not in shame. He's on a big horse, isn't he?
”他用剑拍了拍他的肩膀。“英格兰失去了一位勇敢的骑士随从，却赢得了一位英勇的骑士。不，请不要犹豫，站起来，尼杰尔爵士。”汤姆·霍兰德，这就是阿瑟·柯南·道尔爵士杰作中的高潮场景——他坚信，即便夏洛克·福尔摩斯和华生医生被世人遗忘后，这部作品仍将被长久铭记——这就是《尼杰尔爵士》（Sir Nigel），我们在上一期节目中读到了它的结尾。法兰西骑士精神的精粹如同狗一般被屠戮殆尽。黑太子大获全胜。尼杰尔俘虏了法兰西国王让二世（King Jean II）。正如我们上期节目所听到的，他被带往……实际上，并非带着羞辱。他骑着一匹高头大马，不是吗？
He's led very gallantly through the crowds in London, as would happen, I think, today, if similar scenes were repeated. And England have won the Hundred Years' War, or have they? Well, it certainly looks that way. Because remember, Dominic, it's not just the French king they have. They still have the Scottish king, David II. So they've got a stash of kings. So it's looking tremendous for England and tremendous wealth. So they've had to economize for years and years to fund the war.
他非常威风凛凛地被带过伦敦的街头——我想，如果今天重现类似的场景，也会是这般光景。英格兰赢得了百年战争，还是说并没有？嗯，局势看起来确实如此。因为记住，多米尼克，他们抓到的可不仅仅是法兰西国王。他们手里还有苏格兰国王大卫二世（David II）。所以他们囤积了一堆国王。因此，对英格兰而言，局势看起来好极了，财富也多得惊人。为了资助战争，他们此前已经节衣缩食了多年又多年。
And now the loot is just flooding in. So there's a contemporary chronicler who says a woman who did not possess spoil from France, garments, furs, bed covers, silver vessels, cloth of linen was held of no account. And John, it has to be said, the French king is absolutely leading the way when it comes to showing how to blow loads of cash. So despite the fact that France is going to be bled white to pay for his ransom, I mean, he is spending money like there's no tomorrow. So we have the records of his accounts in London and he bought an organ. He bought whale meat from Bruges. He bought not just one, but six ermine trimmed hats for his jester. Hold on. He's buying all this and having it shipped over to England?
而现在，战利品正源源不断地涌入。当时的一位编年史家写道：“任何一位家里没有法兰西战利品——比如衣物、皮草、床罩、银制器皿、亚麻布——的妇女子民，都会被认为无足轻重。”而且必须承认，约翰，这位法兰西国王在如何挥霍巨额金钱方面，绝对是走在前列的。因此，尽管法兰西将要被榨干来支付他的赎金，我是说，他花钱简直就像没有明天一样。我们保留了他在伦敦的账目记录，他买了一架管风琴。他从布鲁日（Bruges）买回了鲸鱼肉。他不仅买了一顶，还为他的小丑买了好几顶、足足六顶镶有白貂皮边饰的帽子。等等。他买下这一切，还要把它们海运到英格兰来？
Yeah. To London. Yeah. And of course, his youngest son, Philip, is there, 14-year-old boy who'd fought very bravely at Poitiers. Has he got a hat? No doubt he has. Of course, he's got loads of hats. Yes. So massive lavishness from John in London. And of course, there are also loads of French knights. So the flower of French chivalry who've been taken prisoner. So loads of tournaments. In fact, the first ever day night tournament is held in Bristol. A nighttime tournament. Yeah. How do
是的。运到伦敦。是的。当然了，他最小的儿子菲利普（Philip）也在那里，一个14岁的男孩，曾在普瓦捷（Poitiers）英勇作战。他也有帽子吗？毫无疑问，他肯定有。当然了，他有一堆帽子。是的。因此，约翰在伦敦展现出了极度的穷奢极欲。当然，还有许多被俘的法兰西骑士。法兰西骑士精神的精粹都成了阶下囚。因此举办了大量的比武大会。事实上，历史上第一场夜间比武大会就在布里斯托尔（Bristol）举行。一场夜间比武大会。是的。他们是
they do that? They have blazingzing torches so that is the equivalent on this is a lovely link that's the equivalent to the first european floodlit friend is pioneered by wolves in the 1950s under the lights of molyneux when we beat honved and i guess very similar with the top team in in the world in those days the parallel is very obvious i'm glad i can mention that yes st george's day 1358 another great tournament is held, Order of the Garter, chivalry from across not just England, not just France, but the whole of Europe. And a few days later at Windsor, John signs his ransom treaty. And the ransom itself, it's a vast sum. It's about 20 times the ordinary annual revenue of the English king.
怎么做到的呢？他们点燃了熊熊火把——这就相当于（这是一个很棒的类比，这就相当于欧洲第一场灯光足球赛），由狼队（Wolves）在20世纪50年代在莫利纽球场（Molineux）灯光下开创的先河，当时我们击败了洪韦德（Honved）。我猜这与当时世界上最顶级的球队非常相似，这种平行对比非常明显。很高兴我能提到这一点。是的，1358年的圣乔治节（St George's Day），另一场盛大的比武大会隆重举行，嘉德勋章（Order of the Garter），来自不仅是英格兰、不仅是法兰西，而是整个欧洲的骑士们齐聚一堂。几天后在温莎（Windsor），约翰签署了他的赎金条约。至于赎金本身，那是一笔巨额财富。大约相当于英格兰国王普通年收入的20倍。
Crikey. It's agreed that Edward III will rule directly over about a quarter of France. So much expanded Duchy of Aquitaine, Calais, Pontier, a few bits of Normandy, and that he will hold these sovereign so he won't have to do homage to the French king for them. In return, Edward III agrees to give up both his claim to the Duchy of Normandy, which he claims as an inheritance from William the Conqueror, and his claim to the French crown. And just if I can interject, so those bits of France that Edward III will hold, they are no longer French?
天哪。双方商定，爱德华三世（Edward III）将直接统治法兰西大约四分之一的领土。也就是大幅扩张后的阿基坦公国（Aquitaine）、加来（Calais）、蓬蒂厄（Ponthieu），以及诺曼底（Normandy）的一些零散土地，并且他将对这些领土拥有主权，这意味着他无需再为此向法兰西国王效忠。作为交换，爱德华三世同意放弃两项权利：一是他对诺曼底公国的领土主张——他声称这是继承自征服者威廉（William the Conqueror）的遗产，二是他对法兰西王冠的宣称。如果我能打断一下，爱德华三世将要统治的那些法兰西土地，它们不再属于法兰西了吗？
Is that the- Well, they are French. I mean, they're geographically part of France, but legally they are Edward III's, yeah. And Edward feels that these are very reasonable terms. He feels that he's behaved very well. Yeah. And Edward feels that these are very reasonable terms. He feels that he's behaved very well. Meanwhile, however, France is basically disintegrating because in the absence of the king, power has devolved upon the Dauphin, the Dauphin Charles. Yeah. Who, I mean, he is basically a weed, but he's smart.
这是——嗯，它们确实是法兰西的。我是说，从地理上看它们是法兰西的一部分，但从法律上讲，它们属于爱德华三世，是的。爱德华觉得这些条件非常合理。他觉得自己表现得相当不错。是的。爱德华觉得这些条件非常合理。他觉得自己表现得相当不错。然而与此同时，法兰西基本上正在瓦解，因为在国王缺席的情况下，权力已经下放到摄政王、王太子查尔斯（the Dauphin Charles）手中。是的。这个人，我的意思是，他基本上是个弱不禁风的瘦弱书生，但他很聪明。
So he's kind of weedy. He's a bit like me. He's kind of a bit scrawny. It says here he had an ill-proportioned body. Yeah, pale and thin. He had small, sharp eyes, thin lips, a long, thin nose, and an ill-proportioned body. Is that how you describe yourself? I mean, that's a bit harsh.
所以他长得有点弱不禁风。有点像我。他身材有点瘦高。这里写着他“体态失调”。是的，脸色苍白，身材消瘦。他有着细小锐利的眼睛、薄薄的嘴唇、又长又尖的鼻子，以及失调的体态。这是你在形容你自己吗？我的意思是，这未免有点刻薄了。
Well, maybe as I was when I was 20, when I was youth. However, again, like me, beneath his sickly exterior, he possessed a hard core of resistance and a native intelligence, which came to his aid in adversity. Okay, that's good. He really needs it because he is facing multiple crises. So the first and obvious crisis is that Charles the Bad is still very much on the scene. I'd forgotten about him. So listeners to the previous episode, remember Charles the Bad is basically the Mr. Burns of 14th century French history.
好吧，也许就像我20岁、年轻时的样子。不过，同样跟我一样，在他病态的外表下，隐藏着坚韧的抵抗内核与天生的智慧，这在逆境中帮了他大忙。好吧，这倒不错。他确实非常需要这些，因为他正面临着重重危机。首当其冲、显而易见的危机就是，恶人查尔斯（Charles the Bad）依然活跃在政治舞台上。我都把这人给忘了。所以听过前几期节目的听众应该记得，恶人查尔斯基本上就是14世纪法兰西历史上的“伯恩斯先生”（Mr. Burns）。
He does what he says on the tin. I mean, he's just bad. He does things simply because it's tin. I mean, he's just bad. He does things simply because it's bad for the fun of it. So he'd been put in prison by John. He escapes. He escapes in November, 1357. Of course he does. He arrives in Paris. He's treated as an absolute hero. And he starts bullying the Dauphin, the poor old Dauphin, because he wants indemnity for all the lands in Normandy that have been confiscated. And he wants his associates who had been in the conspiracy, who'd been executed on the
他名副其实。我的意思是，他就是个坏蛋。他做事纯粹是因为——我的意思是，他就是个坏蛋。他做事纯粹是为了好玩而作恶。他之前被约翰关进过监狱。他逃跑了。他在1357年11月成功越狱。他当然会这么做。他抵达了巴黎。他被当作绝对的英雄来对待。他开始霸凌王太子，可怜的老王太子，因为他要求归还在诺曼底被没收的所有土地，并且要求为他的同伙平反——那些曾参与阴谋、在约翰的命令下被处决并被吊在绞刑架上的人，他要求为他们举行荣誉葬礼。
orders of John and had been slung up in gibbets, he wants them to be honorably buried. Dauphin kind of plays a holding game. And so what Charles does then is he empties the prisons of Paris and then rides off to Normandy to raise an army. So thoroughly bad behavior. And when he gets to Normandy, he takes the associates, Count of Harcourt and all those people down from the gibbets and buries them. And effectively, he's declaring civil war. So that's bad. The stuff about the prisons is like Bane in The Dark Knight Rises, Tom.
王太子采取了拖延战术。于是，查尔斯做出的举动是：他打开了巴黎的监狱，然后骑马赶往诺曼底去集结军队。这绝对是极其恶劣的行为。当他到达诺曼底时，他把那些同伙——阿库尔伯爵（Count of Harcourt）以及所有那些人的尸体从绞刑架上放了下来，并将他们安葬。实际上，他这是在公开宣战。所以这情况很糟糕。关于监狱的那些事儿，简直就像《黑暗骑士崛起》（The Dark Knight Rises）里的贝恩（Bane）一样，汤姆。
Anyway, that's by the by. Yeah, but it's also like the Wagner Group, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, they're all prisoners, convicts. In Ukraine. Yeah. In Russia, yeah. So that's very much what Charles the Bad is doing. Meanwhile, in Paris, 1789 is not the
不管怎样，这只是题外话。是的，但这也很像瓦格纳集团（Wagner Group），不是吗？是的。我的意思是，他们全都是囚犯、刑事罪犯。在乌克兰。是的。在俄罗斯，是的。所以这跟恶人查尔斯所做的事非常相似。与此同时，在巴黎，1789年并不是巴黎的
first revolution in Paris. You astound me. No. So essentially, there are revolutionary conditions in Paris in the wake of the Battle of Poitiers, because it's not just the authority of the monarchy, but of the nobility as well has been shot. Because aside from the members of the Order of the Star who stood their ground, loads of them had run away, including, you may remember, the Duke of Orléans, the younger brother of the king. And basically, their authority is shot. So it's the third, as in the French Revolution, it's the third estate. So there are
第一次革命。你可真让我大跌眼镜。没有。所以本质上，在普瓦捷战役之后，巴黎正处于革命的氛围中，因为不仅王权的权威荡然无存，贵族的权威也同样土崩瓦解。因为除了星光勋章（Order of the Star）中那些坚守阵地的成员外，许多人都逃跑了，包括你可能还记得的奥尔良公爵（Duke of Orléans），也就是国王的弟弟。基本上，他们的权威已经扫地。所以这就是第三等级——正如在法兰西大革命中那样，这就是第三等级。当时有
the three estates, the nobility, the clergy, and the burghers, the bourgeois. And the bourgeois basically seize control of Paris. They murder two of the Dauphin's closest associates in full view of him. And they invite Charles the Bad back to Paris. They decide that they're going to back him rather than the Dauphin. So the Dauphin escapes, Charles the Bad comes back to Paris. They decide that they're going to back him rather than Dauphin. So the Dauphin escapes. Charles the Bad comes back to Paris. But meanwhile, conditions are so bad that north of Paris, there's a peasant uprising. The Jacquerie is this.
三个等级：贵族、神职人员，以及市民阶层（即资产阶级）。资产阶级基本上夺取了巴黎的控制权。他们在王太子面前公然谋杀了王太子身边的两位亲信。他们还邀请恶人查尔斯回到巴黎。他们决定支持他而不是王太子。于是王太子逃走了，恶人查尔斯回到了巴黎。他们决定支持他而不是王太子。于是王太子逃走了。恶人查尔斯回到了巴黎。但与此同时，局势恶化到了极点，巴黎北部爆发了农民起义。这就是扎克雷起义（the Jacquerie）。
The Jacquerie. So supposedly named after the leader, Jacques Bonhomme. So Jacques, the good man, which sounds a completely made up name and probably was. So Frasier describes it, seeing the wrongs and oppression inflicted on them on every side and seeing the nobles gave them no protection, but rather oppressed them as heavily as the enemy. The peasants rose and took up arms against the nobles of France. And this rebellion only lasts for two weeks. The nightmare for the nobility is that it threatens to spread through France like wildfire. So you get pockets of peasant rebellion in Amiens, throughout Normandy.
扎克雷起义。据说这个名字源于起义领袖雅克·博诺姆（Jacques Bonhomme）。也就是“好人雅克”，听起来像个完全杜撰的名字，而且很可能确实如此。正如弗鲁瓦萨尔（Froissart）所描述的那样：“目睹各方对自己施加的种种不义与压迫，眼见贵族们不仅不予保护，反而像敌人一样对他们重重压迫，农民们奋起反抗，拿起武器对付法兰西的贵族。”这场叛乱仅仅持续了两周。对贵族而言，最大的噩梦在于它威胁着要像野火一样蔓延至整个法兰西。因此，你在亚眠（Amiens）以及整个诺曼底都看到了零星的农民起义。
And the nobility, predictably, are telling awful, nightmarish stories about what this means. So there's one notorious episode where supposedly they capture a knight, they kill him, they put him on a spit, turn him round and round in front of his wife and his children. And then they rape the knight's lady and they try to make her and her children eat the roasted body of the knight. And then when they refuse, they put them to death. I mean, this sounds a wholly improbable story. You don't think this happened? Well, I don't know. I mean, I don't know, but these are the stories that are being told. And so
正如人们所预料的那样，贵族们开始大肆传播那些可怕的、噩梦般的故事，讲述这意味着什么。有一个臭名昭著的事件：据说他们抓到了一名骑士，将他杀死，把他串在烤肉叉上，当着他的妻子和孩子的面转来转去。然后他们强暴了这位骑士的夫人，并试图逼迫她和她的孩子吃下烤熟的骑士尸体。当他们拒绝时，便将他们处死。我的意思是，这听起来是一个完全不可信的故事。你觉得这没有发生过？嗯，我不知道。我是说，我不知道，但这些就是当时流传的故事。因此，
it redounds greatly to Charles the Bad's glory when he is the guy who effectively wipes the jacquerie out, kind of annihilates them. But he then makes a terrible mistake because he moves back to Paris and he tries to seize control of it by setting himself at the head of the third estate of the bourgeois. He proclaims himself the captain of Paris. And this immediately loses him the support of nobility, who previously had swung behind him after he just wiped out the peasants. And so Charles realizes that basically he can't control Paris. No one can control Paris.
当恶人查尔斯成为那个实际上将扎克雷起义彻底扑灭、近乎将其赶尽杀绝的人时，这极大地增添了他的光彩。但他随后犯了一个致命的错误：他搬回了巴黎，并试图通过将自己置于资产阶级第三等级的领导地位来夺取这座城市的控制权。他自封为巴黎的统帅。这立刻让他失去了贵族的支撑——此前，在消灭了农民之后，贵族们曾转而支持他。于是查尔斯意识到，基本上他无法控制巴黎。没有人能够控制巴黎。
It's an absolute state of anarchy. So he withdraws. The Dauphin is already withdrawn. And essentially, the city is left to its own devices. The revolution is going to rage until it burns itself out. So the capital is in a terrible state. The countryside is in a terrible state. But what makes the state of the countryside even worse is you mentioned in the third episode,
这里完全陷入了无政府状态。所以他撤退了。王太子已经撤退了。从本质上讲，这座城市被放任自流。革命将肆虐下去，直到它自行燃尽。因此，首都的状况糟透了。乡村的状况也糟透了。但让乡村局势更加雪上加霜的是——你在第三集中提到过，
is this like the 30 Years' War, where essentially the sense of coherent state entities fighting one another collapses into a kind of more universal anarchy. And this is kind of what happens in the wake of Poitiers, because as the French government disintegrates, all these companies of men who've been fighting with the English, so not just English, but preeminently Gascons, there's no one to hold them in check. And they just start spilling out from Aquitaine, or indeed from Brittany, hold them in check. And they just start spilling out from Aquitaine, or indeed from Brittany, or indeed Normandy. And they just start stripping everything bare. So you get bands of free companies moving southwards from Normandy, northwards from Gascony. And it absorbs so many people that it comes to be called the Great Company.
这是否有点像三十年战争（30 Years' War），当时实体国家之间相互对抗的连贯秩序感彻底崩溃，演变成了一种更加普遍的无政府状态？这正是普瓦捷战役之后发生的情况，因为随着法兰西政府的瓦解，所有这些曾与英格兰人并肩作战的佣兵团——不仅有英格兰人，而且主要是加斯科尼人（Gascons）——再也没有人能约束他们了。他们开始从阿基坦，或者说从布列塔尼，开始从阿基坦，或者说从布列塔尼，或者说从诺曼底蜂拥而出。他们开始洗劫沿途的一切。于是你看到自由佣兵团的队伍从诺曼底向南移动，从加斯科尼向北移动。这支队伍吸收了如此多的人，以至于后来被称为“大佣兵团”（the Great Company）。
And it's led by a former cleric, Arnaud de Savoie, who is called the Archpriest. And basically, they just strip everything bare. So they pillage the whole of Normandy, they head southwards, plundering as they go, and they even menace Avignon, and the Pope has to buy them off. Roughly how many people, would you say? Thousands. I mean, the largest company, yeah. Yeah. So it's the size of a small army, basically. Absolutely. And these are absolutely battle-hardened. These are people who have often fought with the Black Prince.
它由一位前神职人员阿尔诺·德·萨沃（Arnaud de Savoie）率领，人称“大主祭”（the Archpriest）。基本上，他们把一切都洗劫一空。他们蹂躏了整个诺曼底，一路向南推进，边走边抢，甚至威胁到了阿维尼翁（Avignon），逼得教皇不得不花钱把他们打发走。你认为大约有多少人？数千人。我是说，那是规模最大的佣兵团，是的。是的，所以它基本上相当于一支小军队的规模。绝对是的。而且这些人都是百战精锐。他们通常都是跟随黑太子作战过的人。
They know what it is to fight and to kill, and they're masters of the most up-to-date arts of killing. There are archers, men-at-arms. They are terrifying, and there is no one to rein them in. And then on top of all this carnage, of course, when John signs a treaty with Edward III, there's the obligation to pay his ransom. And the problem is, how do you raise it? Because there are no structures of authority. It's just impossible to start raising money. So basically, I mean, it's as bad a condition for France as at any point in its history,
他们懂得如何战斗，懂得如何杀戮，并且精通最新潮的杀戮艺术。那里有弓箭手、重骑兵。他们令人胆寒，而且没有人能够约束他们。而在这一切血腥杀戮之上，当然，当约翰与爱德华三世签署条约时，就有了支付巨额赎金的义务。问题是，你该如何筹集这笔钱？因为根本不存在任何权威结构。要想开始筹集资金简直是不可能的。所以基本上——我的意思是，对法兰西而言，这是其历史上状况最糟糕的时期之一，
maybe after Agincourt, maybe wars of religion in the 16th century. But France is in an absolutely terrible condition. And for the king in London, looking across the channel at this process of Edward III, it's Charles the Bad. They're desperate to leave London, get over and start trying to sort everything out. So the measure of this is that by spring 1359, John is basically ready to sign away everything. And so a fresh treaty is signed in which he basically gives up half the territory of France, including Brittany, including Normandy, to Edward. All of Charles the Bad's territory in Normandy is given to Edward. And when the news of this reaches Paris, the Dauphin is so desperate that he enters into a completely insane plot with the King of Denmark to invade England. Hold on, the Danes haven't invaded England at this point for some considerable time. Yes. So it's kind of very retro, appealing to the Vikings. The plan
也许仅次于阿让库尔（Agincourt），也许比16世纪的宗教战争还要糟。法兰西的处境绝对糟糕透顶。对于身处伦敦、隔着海峡注视着这一切进展的国王爱德华三世来说，还有恶人查尔斯……他们迫切想要离开伦敦，渡过海峡，开始着手理清这一切。这一切的衡量标准就是，到了1359年春天，约翰基本上已经准备好签掉一切了。于是签署了一份新的条约，在其中他基本上将法兰西一半的领土——包括布列塔尼、包括诺曼底——割让给了爱德华。恶人查尔斯在诺曼底的所有领土也都划给了爱德华。当这个消息传到巴黎时，王太子绝望至极，以至于他与丹麦国王勾结，策划了一个极其荒谬的阴谋，企图入侵英格兰。等等，丹麦人在此之前已经有相当长的一段时间没有入侵过英格兰了吧？是的。所以这是一种非常复古的做法，向维京人求助。这个计划
is to kind of rescue John from London and bring him back. And of course, it doesn't work. But it's not just the DOFA who rejects it. The Estates General do as well. So the Estates General, this is the French- Equivalent to the Parliament. The French equivalent to the Parliament. Does the Estates General, I mean, do they have any genuine power or are they purely consultative? Pretty much consultative. But in this condition, they do have power because their ability to refuse it, which they do, they say the terms are unacceptable, impossible, effectively dooms it because they would be responsible for rubber stamping.
是把约翰从伦敦营救出来并带回法兰西。当然，这并没有成功。但不仅是王太子拒绝了这个计划，三级会议（the Estates General）也拒绝了。所以三级会议，这就是法兰西的——相当于议会。法兰西相当于议会。三级会议——我的意思是，他们拥有真正的权力，还是纯粹只有协商权？基本上只是协商权。但在这种情况下，他们确实拥有权力，因为他们有权拒绝——而他们也确实这么做了，他们表示这些条件不可接受、绝无可能——这实际上就注定了条约的失败，因为他们本该负责对条约进行最终核准。
Well, for raising the money, presumably. There's no- For raising the money. There's no presumably very strong state bureaucracy. So it must be entirely dependent on local elites to raise the money for the ransom. If they say no, you're sunk. I mean, mind you, if I was John looking at this situation, I'd probably stay in the Savoy or something. To evict a Hugo. Well, Dominic, it's interesting you say that.
嗯，为了筹集资金，大概是这样。这里没有——为了筹集资金。这里大概并没有非常强大的国家官僚机构。因此，它必定完全依赖地方精英来为赎金筹集资金。如果他们说不，你就彻底完蛋了。不过话说回来，如果我是约翰，面对这种局面，我大概会留在萨沃伊宫（Savoy）或者类似的地方享清福吧。去把雨果（Hugo）赶走。嗯，多米尼克，你这么说很有意思。
Bear that thought in mind. Because, of course, yes, I mean, the condition is terrible. Who would want to take command of a kingdom in this state of anarchy? Well, one person who does is Edward. Basically, when the States General and the Dauphin throw the treaty that he's agreed with the French king back in his face, he decides, well, I'm going to have to go and invade. So that's what he does.
把这个想法记在脑子里。因为，当然啦，是的，目前的状况糟透了。谁会愿意在这个处于无政府状态的国家里接手这样一个烂摊子呢？好吧，确实有一个人愿意，那就是爱德华。基本上，当三级会议和王太子把法国国王同他达成的条约狠狠甩回他脸上时，他决定：“好吧，那我就只能御驾亲征了。”这就是他采取的行动。
And so this is the last time he will lead an expedition to France. He crosses the Calais. He heads south to Reims, which is traditionally where French kings are crowned. And it's pretty obvious that his aim is to have himself crowned in Reims. So he puts the city under siege, but he fails to take it. And so that's a dent in his prestige at a crucial time. This is the first time I think he's had a bit of a reverse. Why don't they take Reims? Why don't they take it? Because it's actually very difficult
所以，这将是他最后一次率领远征军前往法兰西。他穿过加来。他向南挺进至兰斯（Reims），这里传统上是法兰西国王加冕的地方。他的目标显然是想在兰斯给自己加冕，这一点显而易见。于是他下令围攻这座城市，但未能攻克。因此，在这样一个关键时刻，这对他个人的威望是一个打击。我想这是他第一次遭遇挫折。他们为什么不拿下兰斯？为什么拿不下它？因为实际上，攻城
to take cities this is the last point really where cities can be put under siege and expect to hold out right so it you know people are starting to use canon yeah but it's still pretty rough our producer who was gutted in the last episode about the anti-frenchness because he claims to be French he's delighted by the differing pronunciations of R-E-I-M-S in this podcast, Tom. Well, I am speaking the English way here. You are. And I've actually revealed myself. I've made a terrible error. You have with your ragus and your Frenchified ways. Thank God one of us is here to articulate
是非常困难的。这真的是城市能够被围困并指望坚守阵地的最后阶段了，对吧？所以，你知道，人们开始使用大炮了，是的，但它仍然相当原始。我们的制作人在上一集里因为反法兰西情绪而感到沮丧，因为他自称是法兰西人——汤姆，对于这期节目中对“R-E-I-M-S”这个词的不同发音，他感到非常高兴。好吧，我在这里说的是英语发音。确实如此。而且我实际上已经暴露了。我犯了一个严重的错误。你确实犯了错，带着你的拉古斯（ragus）腔和法兰西化的腔调。谢天谢地，我们当中还有一个人能展现出
the bulldog spirit. Anyway, listen, that's a complete tangent. So basically, it's very hard to take a well-defended city. And actually, it's interesting, there haven't been many sieges in this story. Right. The only one really has been Calais, and that took over a year. And that's why it's so difficult then for the French to take it back. Understood. So when Edward III has failed to take... I don't want to say it now, because I'll give myself away. When Edward III has failed... Monsieur Sandbrook. Has failed to take us what's he gonna do now well he has a massive strop yeah he has a massive strop and goes off
这种斗牛犬般的硬汉精神。不管怎样，听着，这完全是个题外话。所以基本上，要攻下一座防御严密的城市是非常困难的。事实上，有趣的是，在这个故事中并没有发生过很多次围城战。没错。唯一真正发生过的围城战是加来，而且持续了一年多。这也是为什么后来法兰西人想要把它夺回会如此困难。明白了。因此，当爱德华三世未能攻克……我现在可不想说这个词，免得我自己说漏嘴。当爱德华三世未能——桑布克先生（Monsieur Sandbrook）。未能攻克那座城市时，他现在打算怎么做？好吧，他大发雷霆。
behaves like a hooligan so he launches a massive chevauchee right the way up to paris where the dauphin is hunkering down and it's designed to humiliate the dauphin to demonstrate that he won't dare come out which he doesn't and actually And actually, Petrarch, the famous Italian humanist, he comes to Paris shortly after this, and he records what he sees. He says that everywhere was grief, destruction, and desolation, uncultivated fields filled with weeds, ruined and abandoned houses. The ruins go right up to the gates of Paris. It'll be like Paris today.
是的，他大发雷霆，表现得像个暴徒。于是他发动了一场大规模的骑兵劫掠战（chevauchée），一路直逼王太子盘踞的巴黎城下。这场行动旨在羞辱王太子，向世人证明王太子根本不敢出城迎战——而他也确实没敢出来。事实上，著名的意大利人文主义者彼特拉克（Petrarch）在此之后不久来到了巴黎，他记录下了自己亲眼所见的一切。他说，到处都是悲伤、毁灭和荒凉，荒芜的田野长满了杂草，房屋破败荒废。废墟一直延伸到了巴黎城门外。这简直就像今天的巴黎一样。
Don't think that you can redeem your reputation with that kind of language. I'm afraid your copy book is so blotted. So that's humiliating for the Dauphin, but it's also a kind of score draw because Edward can't capture Paris. And his inability to capture Paris proclaims to everybody that he can't, even now with France as prostrate as she is that he can't, even now with France as prostrate as she is, he can't really hope to conquer the kingdom outright. And this is a point that is made to him by his greatest lieutenant, the Duke of Lancaster, that great, great warrior, the second knight of the Order of the Garter. So the Duke of Lancaster has been riding with Edward on this chevauchée.
别指望用那种言论来挽回你的名誉。我恐怕你的名册上已经污点斑斑了。这对王太子来说是极大的羞辱，但这也是一场平局，因为爱德华无法攻陷巴黎。他无力攻克巴黎向所有人宣告：哪怕如今的法兰西已经如此虚弱不堪，即便现在法兰西已经虚弱到了这种地步，他也根本无法真正指望彻底征服这个王国。他手下最伟大的将领、兰开斯特公爵（Duke of Lancaster）——那位伟大的、卓越的勇士、嘉德勋章的第二位骑士——向他明确指出了这一点。兰开斯特公爵一直跟随爱德华参与这场骑兵劫掠战。
And as they leave Paris at the spring of 1360, the Duke of Lancaster urges Edward III to negotiate. And again, Frassin records the conversation. I mean, it's probably not verbatim, but it clearly articulates the essence of Lancaster's argument. And Lancaster says to Edward, you now have a choice. You can press on with your struggle and pass the rest of Lancaster's argument. And Lancaster says to Edward, you now have a choice. You can press on with your struggle and pass the rest of your life fighting, or you can make terms with your enemy while you can still come out of it with honour. My advice is to accept the offers which have already been made to you. You know perfectly well that in one day we could lose all that we have gained in 20 years. That's remarkably sensible advice, because he knows that thing that we have gained in 20 years. That's remarkably sensible advice, because he knows that
正当他们于1360年春天离开巴黎时，兰开斯特公爵敦促爱德华三世进行谈判。同样，弗鲁瓦萨尔记录了这段对话。我的名字，这或许并非逐字逐句的原文，但它清晰地阐述了兰开斯特论点的精髓。兰开斯特对爱德华说：“你现在面临一个选择。你可以继续你的斗争，把余生都——”兰开斯特的论点是：“你现在面临一个选择。你可以继续你的斗争，把余生都用来战斗，或者趁你还能全身而退、带着荣誉脱身时，与你的敌人讲和。我的建议是接受已经摆在你面前的提议。你心里非常清楚，我们可能在一天之内，就输掉我们在20年里赢得的一切。”这绝对是非常明智的建议，因为他深知
thing that we talked about in the first couple of episodes, that the English are still in the game while they're winning battles, but because of France's huge advantage in men and in financial power, I mean, once France is back on its feet, once France starts to win, England doesn't have the reserves and the resources, presumably. So he's basically saying, you know, while the going is good, get out now rather than keep gambling. Because ultimately you'll lose. You'll lose one battle and then that will be it. And what he also knows is that England has been incredibly lucky to have the chance to fight three decisive battles.
我们在前几集里讨论过的那件事：英格兰人之所以能留在局中，是因为他们一直在赢得战斗；但由于法兰西在人口和财政实力上占据着巨大优势，一旦法兰西东山再起，一旦法兰西开始赢球，英格兰大概就没有那么多的预备役和资源了。所以他基本上是在说：“趁着局势大好，现在就收手，而不是继续赌下去。因为最终你会输掉。你只要输掉一场战役，那就全完了。”他也深知，
So Suisse, Crecy and Poitiers. And they've won them all. But the likelihood is that the French will not risk battle again. And that means that the English, if the war continues, will be fighting one that they can't possibly win because it will be all about capturing castles, that kind of thing. And the English simply don't have the resources to win a war of that kind. And Edward appreciates this. He accepts the force of what Lancaster is saying. And so May 1360, so only a few weeks after he'd been menacing Paris, he and the Dauphin meet up at Bretigny and negotiations are opened and they last three days. And basically the terms are the
英格兰一直以来幸运至极，才有机会打赢三场决定性的战役——也就是斯鲁伊斯（Sluys）、克雷西（Crecy）和普瓦捷（Poitiers）。他们赢下了所有这些战役。但很可能法兰西人不会再冒险进行决战了。这意味着如果战争继续下去，英格兰将陷入一场绝无可能获胜的战争，因为那将全都是关于攻城略地之类的苦战。而英格兰根本没有资源去打那种战争。爱德华意识到了这一点。他接受了兰开斯特所言的力量。因此在1360年5月，也就是他威胁巴黎几周后，他和王太子在布勒蒂尼（Bretigny）会面，开启了为期三天的谈判。基本上，谈判的条款与
same as those that Edward had negotiated with the Dauphin's father at Windsor 18 months previously. So it leaves Edward with this vastly expanded Duchy of Aquitaine. So it looks as though Aquitaine is now kind of impregnable. And Aquitaine is to be accepted by the French crown as sovereign. And in return, Edward will give up his claim to the French throne. So this seems to be the end of the war. It's a decent result, I would say. It is a decent result, but of course, there are two shadows over it. And the first is that it is less than Edward had been aiming for and that he thought that he'd had within his grasp. So that's a disappointment for him. And the other is the resonance of that comment made by the Duke
18个月前爱德华在温莎与王太子父亲谈判的条款如出一辙。这让爱德华拥有了大幅扩张后的阿基坦公国。因此看起来阿基坦现在似乎固若金汤了。而且阿基坦将作为主权领地被法兰西王室所接受。作为交换，爱德华将放弃他对法兰西王位的宣称。这似乎就是战争的终局了。这是一个不错的结果，我要这么说。这是一个不错的结果，但当然，这上面笼罩着两朵阴影。第一朵阴影是，这比爱德华最初的目标要少，而他原本以为那些都在他的掌控之中。因此这对他来说是个失望。另一个阴影则是兰开斯特公爵那番话的回响：“你心里非常清楚，我们可能在一天之内，就输掉我们在20年里赢得的一切。”所以这就好比——如果我理解错了请纠正我，多米尼克——这就好比一个足球主教练。
of Lancaster. You know perfectly well that in one day we could lose all that we have gained in 20 years. So this is like, I mean, back me up if I'm wrong here, Dominic, but this is like a football manager. Yeah. First half, your team are 8-0 up. Yeah. And he's saying we've got to concentrate on defence because we could still go into halftime, could still be a draw. They could still pull this back. Well, I'll tell you what it is, Tom.
上半场你的球队以8比0领先。而他在说：“我们必须专注于防守，因为我们进入中场休息时仍有可能是平局。他们随时可能扳平比分。”好吧，我来告诉你这是什么情况，汤姆。
To pick up the reference earlier in this episode to Wolves pioneering European football, it's like one of those European Champions League games where away goals count double. You could be winning at home and given the permutations, it might just take one goal by the opponents and suddenly it will all be for nothing and you're out of the tournament.
为了呼应本集节目早些时候关于狼队开创欧洲足球先河的那个梗，这就好比那些客场进球加倍的欧洲冠军联赛。你在主场领先，考虑到各种晋级可能，也许对手只要进一个球，突然之间一切努力都将付诸东流，你就被淘汰出局了。
And that sort of is the position that the English are in, isn't it? Because they cannot come back in the way that the French. So they're sitting on a lead. They're sitting on a lead here. Yeah. They know that it's precarious. Okay. Very good. And fans of England should be warned that the final episode, the final kind of chunk of this series, it's all been going so well, but what is to come, I'm afraid, will be very traumatic. Conversely, if you're French or Scottish, you're going to love what's coming up.
这差不多就是英格兰人当时的处境，不是吗？因为他们无法像法兰西人那样卷土重来。所以他们是在守住领先优势。他们在这里守着领先优势。是的。他们知道这是极其不稳固的。好的。非常棒。需要提醒英格兰队的球迷们注意，最后一集——本系列的最后一部分，虽然目前一切都进展顺利，但接下来要发生的事情，恐怕会非常痛苦。相反，如果你是法兰西人或苏格兰人，你会爱死接下来的剧情的。
Okay. Well, it's good for the soul, Tom. I think sometimes we need to, it's all been wine and roses so far. Sometimes a bit of thin gruel can be good for you. So return after the break for the thin gruel of a French comeback. Yeah. I'm Marina Hyde.
好吧，这有益于灵魂，汤姆。我想有时我们需要——目前为止一切都是顺风顺水。有时吃点粗茶淡饭对你有好处。所以中场休息过后，欢迎回来，品尝法兰西卷土重来的粗茶淡饭。是的。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis rest of entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history we ended the last half with england apparently on top in the
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐圈的内幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。我们在上一半节目的结尾时看到，在布勒蒂尼条约签订后，英格兰人在百年战争中似乎稳操胜券，爱德华三世虽然没有完全得到他想要的一切，但也得到了绝大部分，而法兰西人则陷入了极度的困境。汤姆，但这还远算不上故事的结局，对吧？绝对不算。
hundred years war after the treaty of bretigny edward iii hasn't quite got everything that he wanted but he's got a lot of it the french French very much on their uppers. Tom, this is not quite the end of the story though, is it, by any means? No, it's not. And it looks in the aftermath of the Treaty of Bretigny as though everything is going well for England and specifically for the Black Prince because he becomes Duke of Aquitaine. And so he is the sovereign ruler of this great expanded duchy. And his renown is like nobody else's in Europe. He holds the most extravagant court. This is Camelot.
是的，确实不算。在布勒蒂尼条约签订后，一切似乎都在朝有利于英格兰、尤其是黑太子的方向发展，因为他成为了阿基坦公爵。因此，他是这片庞大扩张公国的主权统治者。他的声望在欧洲无人能及。他举办了极其奢华的宫廷宴会。这就是卡米洛特（Camelot）。
They all loved and honored him as their lord. Frassar writes about his courtiers. He proclaimed his realm to be the greatest in the world and the richest in valiant men at arms. And so the Black Prince is absolutely preeminent as the model, not just of chivalry, but of a kind of earthly rule. Because by now, Edward III is starting to get old, but the Black Prince is absolutely in his prime. However, that said, the foundations of English rule remain precarious. And that's because France remains in a terrible way. So the territories that England has absorbed, they've been ravaged and plundered.
每个人都爱戴他、尊崇他为自己的领主。弗鲁瓦萨尔这样描写他的朝臣们。他宣称自己的领地是世界上最伟大、拥有最多勇猛骑士的富庶之邦。因此，黑太子作为骑士精神、乃至某种尘世统治的楷模，地位绝对是无出其右的。因为此时，爱德华三世开始老去，但黑太子正值壮年。然而话虽如此，英格兰统治的基础依然摇摇欲坠。这是因为法兰西的处境依然极其糟糕。英格兰吞并的那些领土此前饱受蹂躏与劫掠。
So the sense of social instability in these new lands that are now constituting the Duchy of Aquitaine is very pronounced. And it's telling that the Prince of Wales finds it as hard to rein in the free companies as the French crown does. So, Froissart, he thinks that Edward III deliberately encourages English soldiers who've been left unemployed by the Treaty of Bretigny to stay in France because he doesn't want them coming back to England. Because he's worried about the instability that they will spread. And there may well be truth to that. But of course, the knock-on effect of that is that they remain and they destabilize the Black Prince's duchy.
因此，构成阿基坦公国的新土地上，社会动荡不安的感觉非常强烈。而且很说明问题的是，威尔士亲王（the Prince of Wales）发现，要约束这些自由佣兵团，和法兰西王室一样困难。因此，弗鲁瓦萨尔认为，爱德华三世是故意鼓励那些因布勒蒂尼条约而失业的英格兰士兵留在法兰西，因为他不想让他们回到英格兰。因为他担心他们会散播不稳定因素。这其中可能确实有几分真。但当然，随之而来的连锁反应是，他们留了下来，并破坏了黑太子公国稳定。
I mean, lots of them go to Italy, where the Italians are absolutely kind of devastated by the arrival of all these. So the most famous one of these is Hawkwood, John Hawkwood. There's a wonderful book, I think, by Francis Stunner Saunders about Hawkwood's company kind of just rampaging across you know tuscany and northern italy and here there and everywhere pillaging and this is basically this is a bit like one of these middle eastern you know iraq and syria where there's the war spills over the borders yeah and neighboring states are kind of dragged into it absolutely so there's blow and for england
我的意思是，他们中的许多人去了意大利，意大利人被这些人的到来彻底祸害了。其中最著名的一个人就是霍克伍德（Hawkwood），约翰·霍克伍德（John Hawkwood）。我记得弗朗西斯·斯通纳·桑德斯（Francis Stonner Saunders）写过一本精彩的书，讲述了霍克伍德的佣兵团如何在托斯卡纳（Tuscany）、意大利北部以及各个地方横行霸道、四处劫掠。这基本上——这就有点像中东地区，比如伊拉克和叙利亚，那里的战争蔓延到了国境线之外，邻国也被拖了进去。绝对是的。所以这会产生反噬。对于英格兰来说，
there's blowback because lots do of of course, go back to England. And these are men who are absolutely honed in the art of pillaging and intimidating. And so not as bad as France, but social order in England starts to break down because of the return of these members of the company. And there is something there that is foreshadowing the possibility of a kind of peasant revolt of the Order of the Jacquerie that France has already suffered. So that's something that perhaps is starting to brew at this point. And I think it is true to say that despite the aura of glamour that surrounds the Black Prince and the Order of the Garter, there's no question that people in England are aware that ultimately
也会有反噬，因为确实有很多人回到了英格兰。而这些人都是在劫掠和恐吓艺术中千锤百炼的老手。因此，虽然情况没有法兰西那么糟，但由于这些佣兵团成员的回归，英格兰的社会秩序也开始崩溃。其中确实有一些迹象，预示着可能爆发类似于法兰西已经遭受过的雅克雷起义那样的农民起义。所以这或许正是当时开始酝酿的事情。我认为可以肯定地说，尽管黑太子和嘉德勋章周围环绕着耀眼的光环，但毫无疑问，英格兰民众心里清楚，归根结底，
English victories have been won by the longbowmen. And this does seem to have had, I think, a knock-on effect on the confidence of the commons. So the first record we have of the commons meeting separately from the lords is in 1341, which is the year after the Battle of Sluice. 1351, so a decade on, they're taking control of the wool trade, so from the monarch. And the class of people who had been providing the longbowmen in England start to be enfranchised. You have to have a longbow if you have 40 shillings of land income in property. So you're legally obliged to own a bow. Is that right? That's right.
英格兰的胜利是由长弓手赢得的。这似乎确实对普通民众的自信心产生了连锁反应。我们关于下议院与上议院分开开会的有据可查的第一次记录是在1341年，也就是斯鲁伊斯战役发生的次年。1351年，也就是十年后，他们开始从君主手中接管羊毛贸易的控制权。在英格兰提供长弓手的阶层开始获得选举权。如果你拥有价值40先令土地收入的财产，你就必须配备一张长弓。所以你在法律上有义务拥有一张弓。是这样吗？正是如此。
And that also, however, means that you are legally entitled to vote. Yeah. And so that gives a certain degree of voting power to the classes who won, Crecy and Poitiers. So England has become a political nation of longbowmen. Well, in the long run, the reign of Edward III will be remembered as much for the growing autonomy of parliaments as for the victories in France. So it's having unexpected consequences in England as well as in France. I think also there is, certainly on the part of the Black Prince, there is a measure of overconfidence. Everything has gone so well for him since he was 16 that he can't contemplate the possibility that things might go wrong. So the Herald of Sir John Shandos, and Sir John Shandos is there with the Black Prince in Aquitaine, he describes the rule of the Black Prince as being marked by good sense, moderation, righteousness, reason, justice, and restraint. The truth is that none of these descriptions really apply to the rule of the Black Prince.
然而这也意味着，你在法律上有权进行投票。是的。这就赋予了赢得克雷西和普瓦捷战役的那些阶层一定程度的投票权。因此，英格兰已经变成了一个由长弓手组成的政治民族。从长远来看，爱德华三世的统治不仅因在法兰西的胜利而被铭记，同样也因议会日益增强的自治权而被后人铭记。因此，这不仅在法兰西，也在英格兰产生了意想不到的后果。我认为，黑太子身上也确实存在一定程度的过度自信。自16岁以来，一切对而言都太顺风顺水了，以至于他根本无法想象事情可能会出岔子。因此，约翰·钱多斯爵士（Sir John Shandos）的传令官——而约翰·钱多斯爵士当时正与黑太子一同在阿基坦——他将黑太子的统治描述为以明智、温和、正直、理智、公正和克制为标志。事实是，这些描述没有一个真正适用于黑太子的统治。
He's all about extravagance, and this has to be paid for. So the Black Prince has begun to tax his lands in England quite heavily to fund his court in Bordeaux. But he also starts to impose taxes in a way that they've never been exacted before, not just on Gascony, but on the lands beyond Gascony that have been brought in by the terms of the Treaty of Bretonny into his duchy. And his subjects don't like this, and they start to grumble. And they start to think, well, is there someone else? Is there someone we could appeal to? And of course, the obvious person that they can appeal to is the French king, even though legally by the terms of the treaty, they're not allowed to. But that's a kind of possibility that is starting to bubble away.
他热衷于穷奢极欲，而这一切都必须付出代价。因此，黑太子开始在英格兰对其领地征收重税，以资助他在波尔多（Bordeaux）的宫廷。但他不仅开始以前所未有的方式在加斯科尼征税，而且还在布勒蒂尼条约条款划入他公国范围的加斯科尼以外的土地上征税。他的臣民不喜欢这样，并开始发牢骚。他们开始琢磨：难道没有别人了吗？难道没有我们可以申诉的对象吗？当然，他们能申诉的显而易见的人选就是法兰西国王，尽管按照条约条款，他们在法律上是不被允许这么做的。但这正是开始暗流涌动的一种可能性。
And meanwhile, the Black Prince, he's possibility that is starting to bubble away. And meanwhile, the Black Prince is always looking for opportunities to burnish his glory yet more. And the chance comes in 1366, when there's a kind of Spanish adventure involving various rivals for the throne of Castile. He leads an expedition there, including lots of the free companies. He meets with the French army, defeats the French army yet again. So this absolutely sets the seal on England's reputation for military prowess. But the long-term consequences are disastrous for the Black Prince on a personal level, because he contracts a very debilitating illness, perhaps malaria, I don't know. But he's double-crossed by his Spanish allies, the guy who he's been kind of backing as King of Castile. And so he's left very heavily in debt, comes back to Aquitaine, raises taxes even higher. And this is a real problem now because John II, the Treaty of Bretigny, he and his young son, Philip, come back to France. Everything he does continues to be disaster. So he tries to hire the archpriest,
与此同时，黑太子开始逐渐成为一个不容忽视的隐患。与此同时，黑太子一直在寻找机会来进一步擦亮他的赫赫战机。这个机会在1366年到来，当时卡斯蒂利亚王位之争引发了一场西班牙冒险之旅。他率领了一支远征军前往那里，其中包含了许多自由雇佣军团。他与法军遭遇，再次击败了法军。这彻底巩固了英格兰在军事威望上的声誉。但从长远来看，这给黑太子个人带来了灾难性的后果，因为他染上了一种非常虚弱的疾病，可能是疟疾，我不太清楚。但他被自己的西班牙盟友背叛了，也就是他一直以来支持的那个卡斯蒂利亚国王候选人。因此他负债累累，回到阿基坦后，进一步提高了税收。现在这成了一个真正的问题，因为在布勒丁尼条约签订后，约翰二世和他的小儿子菲利普回到了法国。他所做的一切继续引发灾难。所以他试图雇用副祭司，
the leader of the most, the great company. That goes wrong, unsurprisingly. He gets double-crossed. Then he decides, oh, hang this. I'm going to go on a crusade. That goes wrong. And basically, everything seems to be going so badly that you said earlier, why did he ever leave England? Well, he goes back to England. And his explanation for this is that he's unable to keep the terms of the treaty because he can't pay the ransom. He can't control the free companies. And so, therefore, he's going to go back to London. And he gives this kind of high sounding declaration that if good faith and honor to be banished from the world, still let them be found in the hearts and words of princes. But everybody in France is kind
也就是那支最大雇佣兵团的领袖。不出所料，事情搞砸了。他被背叛了。接着他决定，去他的。我要去进行一次十字军东征。结果又搞砸了。基本上，一切似乎都糟透了，正如你刚才所说，他当初为什么要离开英格兰？好吧，他回到了英格兰。他对此的解释是，他无法遵守条约条款，因为他付不起赎金。他无法控制那些自由雇佣军团。因此，他决定返回伦敦。他发表了一番冠冕堂皇的声明，大意是如果世上再无诚信与荣誉，那它们也应当在诸侯的心中和言语中找到容身之所。但法国的所有人都在
of screaming at him, don't do this. So he goes back to London and within four months he's dead. So he's dead in April 1364. His body is returned to France with all honor. But this means that the Dauphin, Charles, is now king. And he's the ill-proportioned fellow. So he looks like Blackadder in the very first Blackadder series. But he's very shrewd. Right. He has lots of cunning plans, and they genuinely are cunning. And his chief cunning plan is basically to take back the lands that his father ceded.
冲他大喊，别这么做。于是他回到了伦敦，在四个月内就去世了。所以他在1364年4月去世了。他的遗体带着全部荣耀被送回法国。但这也意味着，王太子查尔斯现在成为了国王。他是一个身材比例失调的家伙。他看起来就像第一季《黑爵士》里的黑爵士。但他非常精明。没错。他有很多狡猾的计划，而且确实非常狡猾。他最主要的狡猾计划，基本上就是夺回他父亲割让的土地。
Okay. I mean, it doesn't have to be that cunning to think of that. That's surely an obvious goal. But he plays a long game. He delayed gratification because he realizes that, you know, as you've been pointing out throughout these episodes, that France has much, much greater resources and the requirement is to marshal them and to apply them where it will hurt the English. And so what he does is as he starts to reintroduce order, as revenues start to increase, he deploys these increased revenues essentially in winning back the loyalty of lords and castellans in
好吧。我的意思是，想出这一点其实不需要多狡猾。这显然是一个显而易见的目标。但他采取的是长线策略。他克制了自己的即时满足感，因为他意识到——正如你在这些剧集里一直指出的那样——法国拥有大得多的资源，关键在于如何统筹这些资源，并将其用在能狠狠打击英格兰的地方。因此，随着他开始重建秩序，随着税收不断增加，他将这些增加的收入主要用于重新赢得法国境内被英格兰占领地区的领主和城堡主们的效忠。
English-occupied regions of France. And the other thing he does is he appoints as constable, so in other words, military supremo in France, he appoints a constable not on the basis of aristocratic pedigree, but on raw ability. And the man he appoints is a professional captain, the most famous of all the leaders of armed bands in France, a man who'd already fought and actually lost to the back prince in Spain, but whose reputation is beyond compare in France. And this is a man called Bertrand du Guiscard. And by the time that he's appointed constable, he has made himself the richest of all the various soldiers of fortune who've been profiting from the atmosphere of chaos in France. He's not a great tactician in the way
他做的另一件事是任命了一位统帅，也就是法国的最高军事统帅。他任命统帅的标准不是看贵族血统，而是看绝对的能力。他任命的人是一位职业队长，是法国所有武装帮派领袖中最著名的一个，一个曾经在西班牙与黑太子交过手甚至还输给过黑太子、但在法国享有无与伦比声誉的人。这个人名叫贝特朗·杜·盖克兰。当他被任命为统帅时，他已经成为了法国因混乱局势而发财的各路战争财阀中最富有的人。他不是那种具有伟大战术眼光的统帅，
that Sir John Chandos is or the Black Prince, but he's a brilliant, brilliant strategist. I mean, he's the equal, if not the superior to Edward III because he absolutely recognises that there can be no question of meeting the English in an open battle. And he understands that it's got to be a war of attrition and that if they stick to that discipline, the English can't possibly win that. And so he exercises absolute control. He plans everything. And he essentially is completely adept at moving pieces on the chessboard in a way that increasingly comes to kind of put English positions in France increasingly into a kind of condition of checkmate.
不像约翰·钱多斯爵士或黑太子那样，但他是一位极其卓越的战略家。我的意思是，他完全不逊色于爱德华三世，甚至可能更胜一筹，因为他绝对清楚，与英格兰人在公开战场上硬碰硬是绝无可能的。他明白，这是一场消耗战，只要他们坚持这种纪律，英格兰人就绝无可能取胜。因此，他行使了绝对的控制权。他策划了一切。基本上，他极其擅长在棋盘上移动棋子，一步步将法国境内的英格兰势力逼入一种类似将死的绝境。
And by 1368, Charles V, the former Dauphin, is ready to make his move because an appeal comes to him from all the people in Aquitaine who were being taxed by the Black Prince. And Charles summons the Black Prince to answer for this. And of course, the Black Prince refuses because he's sovereign. He has no answerable to the French king. Absolutely. And so Charles V, in response to this, he doesn't declare war, but he launches troops against English possessions in Aquitaine, and they promptly start to collapse. And Edward III in London, who's still very confident of his ability to impose terms, promptly rips up the treaty and reclaims the French throne. But this time it all goes tits up. It's an absolute disaster. And the English positions just disintegrate and implode. And I mean, rather than kind of describe each process by which this happens, because it's a
到了1368年，前王太子查理五世已经准备好采取行动了，因为阿基坦所有被黑太子课以重税的人都向他发出了申诉。查理传唤黑太子对此做出交代。当然，黑太子拒绝了，因为他是主权者。他无需对法国国王负责。确实如此。因此，查理五世对此作出的反应是，他没有宣战，而是对阿基坦境内的英格兰领地发动了军队，这些领地随即开始瓦解。而身在伦敦的爱德华三世依然对自己的强硬姿态充满自信，立刻撕毁了条约并重新索取法国王位。但这一次，一切都彻底搞砸了。这是一场绝对的灾难。英格兰人的阵地直接土崩瓦解、全面溃败。我的意思是，与其去描述这一切发生的具体过程，因为这是一个
long and frankly, if you're English, rather depressing story, I will describe what happens to some of the lead players, the people who've been taking the starring roles in the story so far. Just before you do that, Tom, the war has been over 30 years at this point, hasn't it? So just sort of generationally, I suppose, some of those characters, Edward III, Chandos or whatever, they must be slightly past their prime by this point. Is there a sense of that? They are. Yeah. So Sir John Shandos, he dies quite early in this campaign. There's a French incursion. It's fought on a riverbank. He wins the battle because he always wins his battles, but he's going up a riverbank. He slips on his surcoat, falls to his knees and gets stabbed through the face. That's a very unglamorous end
漫长且坦白说，如果你是个英国人，会觉得相当压抑的故事，不如我来描述一下其中几位主角的命运，也就是目前为止在故事中扮演主要角色的那些人。在你这么做之前，汤姆，这个时候战争已经持续了30多年了，对吧？所以从代际上讲，我想其中的一些角色，比如爱德华三世、钱多斯之流，在这个时候肯定已经有点过了巅峰期了。有这种感觉吗？确实有。是的。所以约翰·钱多斯爵士在这场战役的早期就阵亡了。当时有一场法军的入侵。战斗在河岸边打响。他赢得了战斗，因为他总是能赢得战斗，但当他沿着河岸前进时，
for a glamorous man. Yeah, it is. And he dies a few hours later without ever regaining consciousness. And the English recognize that they've lost their best soldier, their best strategist, their best tactician. And it's bad for the Black Prince because he's lost his lieutenant. The fate of the Black Prince is, I mean, people who feel that he deserves a measure of retribution for his readiness to slaughter and kill his social inferiors. Well, what happens to him is that once war has been declared again between England and France, lots of cities that have been given to the Black Prince in his role as Duke of Aquitaine throw off their loyalty to him. One of them is the city of Limoges in central France. Black Prince is furious. He's incredibly ill by this point. He still seems to be suffering from malaria, but he leads an expedition against Limoges. He captures it and he wipes it out. And this is,
他的战袍滑落了，导致他双膝跪地，随后被长矛刺穿面部。对于一个风光无限的人来说，这真是一个毫无光彩的结局。是的，确实如此。他在几个小时后去世了，至死都没有恢复意识。英格兰人意识到，他们失去了一位最优秀的士兵、最好的战略家、最好的战术家。这对外黑太子来说是个沉重的打击，因为他失去了自己的得力干将。至于黑坦子的命运——我的意思是，那些觉得他对屠杀和残害社会地位低于自己的人应该受到一定惩罚的人会怎么看呢？好吧，在他发生的事情是，一旦英格兰和法国重新开战，许多曾被封给身为阿基坦公爵的黑太子的城市纷纷背叛了他。其中一座城市就是法国内陆的利摩日。黑太子勃然大怒。此时的他已经病入膏肓。他似乎仍在饱受疟疾的折磨，但他还是率领了一支远征军讨伐利摩日。他攻陷了这座城市，并将其血洗。这就是，
you asked, well, you know, are people worrying about the scale of the atrocities? At this point, Froissart does. Right. You know, he says of the people who were slaughtered by the Black Prince, let the Lord receive their souls for they were all martyrs. And he writes this kind of incredibly moving passage, very unusual in the context of medieval chroniclers, kind of saying that fate visited on Limoge was terrible. Although Tom, I have to say, I read online that the Black Prince has been greatly maligned. The historian Richard Barber says probably only a tenth of the number of people that Frassar says were killed were in fact killed. And this is fake news. The Black Prince was a tremendous fellow. It's not entirely fake news because even a tenth of the number of people that Frassar says were killed were in fact killed. And this is fake news. The Black Prince was a tremendous fellow.
你可能会问，大家难道不担心暴行的规模吗？此时的傅华沙确实担心了。没错。你知道的，他对那些被黑太子屠杀的人说：愿主安抚他们的灵魂，因为他们都是殉道者。他写下了这段极其感人的文字，这在中世纪编年史家中是非常罕见的，大意是降临在利摩日的命运是可怕的。尽管汤姆，我不得不说，我在网上看到有人说黑太子被严重抹黑了。历史学家理查德·巴伯说，实际被杀的人数可能只有傅华沙所说十分之一。这是假新闻。黑太子是个了不起的家伙。这并非完全是假新闻，因为即使是傅华沙所说人数的十分之一，
It's not entirely fake news because even a tenth of the population is still in enormous proportion and it's designed to be salutary. Right. That's what the Black Prince is all about. It's about giving public lessons. You know, this is chivalric. It's perfectly acceptable. But it is, well, black, you might say. It feeds to his reputation as a black prince.
人口基数依然极其庞大，而且这种屠杀本来就是为了杀鸡儆猴。没错。这就是黑太子的作风。就是要起到公开杀一儆百的作用。你知道的，这很骑士精神。这是完全可以接受的。但你可以说，这也挺黑暗的。这正好符合他“黑太子”的名声。
And the effort of conducting this campaign is such that he has to be carried back to Bordeaux in a litter. And a few months later, early 1371, he goes back to England and gives up his duchy. He can't. Crikey. He's a broken man. Is this because of malaria, basically? Yeah, malaria. Yes, it seems to be. And so he moves to his great manor at Kennington, which is about 30 minutes walk from where
为了进行这场战役，他耗费了巨大的心力，最后不得不坐着轿子被抬回波尔多。几个月后，即1371年初，他回到了英格兰并放弃了他的公国。他撑不下去了。天哪。他已经心力交瘁了。这基本上是因为疟疾吗？是的，疟疾。是的，似乎是的。于是他搬到了位于肯宁顿的宏伟庄园，从我
I'm sitting now. Yeah, the Oval. And so the coat of arms, the badge of Surrey Cricket Club is the ostrich feather, which derives ultimately from the Black Prince, who owned the land on which the Oval now stands. And that ostrich feather, of course, ultimately derives from John the Blind King of Bohemia. And to this day, Surrey Cricket Club are the tenants of the Prince of Wales. So that's all very sad. And he then contracts dysentery.
现在坐的地方步行大约30分钟就能到。对，就在椭圆球场（Oval）。因此，萨里板球俱乐部的徽章和标志是鸵鸟羽毛，这最终源自拥有如今椭圆球场所在土地的黑太子。而那根鸵鸟羽毛，当然最终源自波西米亚的盲王约翰。直到今天，萨里板球俱乐部依然是威尔士亲王的租户。所以这一切都非常令人伤感。随后他又感染了痢疾。
Yeah. Very humiliating way to go. And he dies in 1376 and is buried in Canterbury Cathedral next to the shrine of Thomas Beckett, the great martyred saint. And if you go to Canterbury, you can see his shield, his coats of arms, his helmet. Wikipedia tells me, Tom, that his dysentery had become so violent on occasion that he would faint from weakness. Yeah. If we have French or Scottish listeners, they may feel that certain degree of poetic justice there. Obviously, we don't as patriotic Englishmen. We don't think that at all, of course. And if that's an awful fate that's visited on the Prince of Wales, the Black Prince, then
是的。以这种方式谢幕实在太屈辱了。他在1376年去世，被安葬在坎特伯雷大教堂，紧邻伟大殉道圣人托马斯·贝克特的圣坛。如果你去坎特伯雷，还能看到他的盾牌、纹章和头盔。维基百科告诉我，汤姆，他的痢疾有时发作得如此剧烈，以至于他会虚弱得昏厥过去。是的。如果我们有法国或苏格兰听众，他们可能会觉得那里有一种某种程度上的报应。当然，作为爱国的英国人，我们并没有这种感觉。我们当然绝不会这么想。如果说这是降临在威尔士亲王（黑太子）身上的可怕命运，那么
in a way, the fate of Edward III, the greatest lad ever to sit on the throne of England, the ladies' man, the supreme strategist of his generation, is even worse because he becomes very senile. He ends up with dementia. He becomes the plaything of a woman called Alice Peres, who Philippa by this point has died. So he comes under the thumb of Alice Peres, who is predictably not treated well by the chroniclers of the age. And he ends up dying in Sheen, which is one would wish on anyone. Is Sheen a terrible place? I mean, I don't think that's... It's where you'd want to go if you were a great warrior.
在某种程度上，爱德华三世——这个坐上英格兰王位最伟大的小伙子、情圣、他那一代最卓越的战略家的命运则更为悲惨，因为他变得非常痴呆。他最终患上了老年痴呆症。他成为了一个名叫爱丽丝·佩雷斯的女性的玩物，因为此时菲莉帕王后已经去世了。因此他落入了爱丽丝·佩雷斯的掌控之中，而正如人们所料，当时的编年史家对她没有什么好脸色。他最终死在显（Sheen），这是谁都不愿意遭遇的归宿。显是一个糟糕的地方吗？我的意思是，我不认为那是……如果你是一个伟大的勇士，那是你想要归宿的地方。
Isn't Sheen where you and I went and had a dinner for charity? As Moorlake. They're not the same place? That's just down from there. Those places on the Thames all blur into one in my mind. Yeah. Well, anyway, he died there and that's the end of him. Well, no. I mean, so shortly before and that's the end of him. Well, no.
显难道不是你和我去吃慈善晚宴的地方吗？就在莫尔莱克（Moorlake）。它们不是同一个地方吗？就在那附近。在我脑海里，泰晤士河边的那些地方全都混成了一团。好吧。不管怎样，他死在那儿了，他的一生也就此结束。好吧，并没有。我的意思是，就在他去世前不久，他的一生就这样结束了。好吧，没有。
I mean, so shortly before he dies, the measure of how, you know, this great warrior is that a group of representatives from London come to visit him. Yeah. And they have to kind of swaddle him up like a baby in cloth of gold and they nail him into the throne. So they kind of hammer down the cloth so that he can stay upright. And he's, you know, he kind of sits there like a kind of doll. But he wasn't that old.
我的意思是，就在他去世前不久，为了展示这位伟大的战士究竟沦落到了何种地步，伦敦的一群代表来看望他。是的。他们不得不把他像个婴儿一样用金丝织物包裹起来，然后把他钉在王座上。所以他们把织物钉死，好让他能保持坐姿。而他呢，你知道的，就那么像个洋娃娃一样坐在那里。但他当时并不是那么老。
He was 64 when he died. Yeah. Very sad. Okay. Very sad. And so he dies a year after the Black Prince and his last words are, Jesus, you have pity. And he dies. He's lost all his lands in France by this point. Yeah. So the Duke of Lancaster's warning has proved true. Now you may be wondering, of course, it's not just the English leaders who come to horrible ends. Because, of course, you will remember Charles the Bad. Yeah. Is he a friend of the show?
他去世时才64岁。是的。非常令人伤感。好吧。非常令人伤感。于是他在黑太子死后一年去世了，他的遗言是：耶稣，求你垂怜。然后他就咽气了。此时他已经失去了在法国的所有土地。是的。所以兰开斯特公爵的警告应验了。现在你们可能在想，当然，遭遇可怕结局的不仅仅是英格兰的领袖们。因为，当然，你们还记得恶人查理吧。是的。他是节目的常客吗？
I'm not sure. I don't think he's a friend of the show, but he's definitely... He's a character in the show, isn't he? Yeah. If I was employing a plotter, I'd look to him. Yeah, definitely. Yeah. So basically, he gets outsmarted by his old enemy, Charles V.
我不确定。我不觉得他是节目的常客，但他绝对是……他是节目里的一个角色，对吧？是的。如果我要雇佣一个阴谋家，我肯定会找他。没错，绝对的。所以基本上，他被他的老对手查理五世给智取了。
Okay. And he gets pursued absolutely relentlessly. And by the final decade of his life, he's lost all his holdings in France. He has to retreat to Navarre. Every so often the French will come barging into Navarre and loot it. So he's in a very bad way. And in 1387, so that's 10 years after the death of Edward III, he is in the Pamplona and he's in a very bad way physically. And so his physician orders him to be wrapped up in a kind of linen cloth, which for some reason the physician says has to be dipped in brandy. I'm just reading the description. It's absolutely hilarious. Hold on, hold on. So he's like a kind of massive baby wrapped up in swaddling clothes. This kind of, this cloth that's been soaked in brandy
好吧。他遭到了无休止的追捕。在他生命的最后十年里，他在法国的所有领地都丢光了。他不得不退守纳瓦拉。法军时不时会闯入纳瓦拉进行洗劫。所以他的处境非常糟糕。在1387年，也就是爱德华三世死后10年，他在潘普洛纳，当时的身体状况糟糕透顶。于是他的御医命令用某种亚麻布将他全身包裹起来，出于某种原因，医生说这种布必须浸泡在白兰地里。我正在读这段描述。这简直太滑稽了。等等，等等。所以他就像一个用襁褓包裹起来的巨大婴儿。这种布浸透了白兰地，
right the way up to his neck. So he can't actually move. You know, he can't move his legs. He can't move his arms. This is done to him every night. And then in a very Game of Thrones way, one of the kind of, you know, the chambermaids whose duty it is to attend to him she
一直包裹到他的脖子。所以他实际上根本无法动弹。你知道的，他的腿动不了。他的手臂也动不了。每天晚上都要对他的身体这么做。然后，在一个非常像《权力的游戏》的桥段中，其中一个负责照顾他的侍女，
she accidentally drops a candle onto this brandy impregnated cloth that he's wrapped in and uh it goes whoosh and the chambermaid is goes oh my god what have i done she runs out in panic and charles the bold is horribly burned to death what a way to go crikey yeah so so that's all uh that's all bad but there are survivors so one of the survivors is john of gaunt edward the third second son oh yeah so he's only been mentioned in this podcast of the capacity of being born so born in game but he's yeah he's the great survivor from that golden age of English chivalry and victory. And he's actually the person who in 1373 leads the last great chevauchee.
不小心把一根蜡烛掉在了他身上包裹的、浸透了白兰地的布上，然后“呼”地一下着了火，那个侍女吓得大喊“天哪我做了什么”，她惊慌失措地跑了出去，而恶人查理就这样被活活烧死了。这算什么死法啊！天哪。是的，所以这一切都……这一切都很糟糕，但还是有幸存者的。幸存者之一就是冈特的约翰，爱德华三世的次子。哦，是的。所以他在本播客中此前仅仅以“出生”的身份被提及过……出生在根特。但他的确是……他是英格兰骑士精神与胜利那个黄金时代的伟大幸存者。他实际上就是在1373年率领最后一次伟大骑兵劫掠（Chevauchee）的人。
So he goes from Calais all the way to Bordeaux. But it's a bit of a Pyrrhic march because even though he does successfully cross the whole of France, by the time he reaches Bordeaux, most of his troops have been wiped out. And that's effectively the last of the great chevauchees that are launched in this stage of the Hundred Years' War. And John of Gaunt becomes increasingly unpopular because the blame for the collapse of England's positions in France are laid at his door. The person who really comes out of it well is Charles V, who ends up being called Charles the Wise. He dies in 1380 and his achievements are absolutely manifest. He's basically picked France up from being utterly prostrate, kind of set it back on its feet again. He's retaken most of the conquests made by the English with the striking exception of Calais,
所以他从加莱一路打到波尔多。但这其实是一场得不偿失的行军，因为尽管他确实成功穿越了整个法国，但当他到达波尔多时，他的大部分军队都已经被消磨殆尽了。这实际上也就是百年战争这一阶段发动的最后一次大规模骑兵劫掠。而冈特的约翰也变得越来越不受欢迎，因为英格兰在法国阵地的崩溃被归咎于他的头上。真正全身而退、名利双收的人是查理五世，他最终被称为“贤明查理”。他在1380年去世，他的成是有目共睹的。他基本上把濒临彻底崩溃的法国重新扶了起来。他收复了绝大部分被英国人征服的领土，其中最耀眼的例外是加莱，
which remains in English holds. He's defeated Charles the Bad, and basically he's done as well as any French king could have hoped to do. However, both France and England remain in very bad ways. They're both very badly scarred by the experience of the war. England is in a position of increasing instability because of English men-at-arms who are returning from the war, kind of embittered, hard to control, contemptuous of authority. France France likewise, France remains very, very scarred by the free companies, by the depredations of English armies. Both countries remain very, very heavily taxed. And both countries in the wake of the death of respectively Edward III and Charles V have very young and inexperienced kings. So the king who succeeds Edward III is the son of the
加莱仍然控制在英国人手中。他击败了恶人查理，基本上，他做得和任何一个法国国王所能期望的最好结果一样好。然而，法国和英国的处境依然非常糟糕。两国都深受战争创伤的摧残。由于从战场返回的英国男兵变得愤世嫉俗、难以管教、蔑视权威，英格兰正陷入日益不稳定的状态之中。同样，法国也依然饱受自由雇佣军和英格兰军队蹂躏的创伤。两国都承受着极重的赋税。并且，在爱德华三世和查理五世分别去世之后，两国都迎来了非常年轻且缺乏经验的国王。因此，继承爱德华三世王位的是
black prince, Richard, who'd been born in Bordeaux. So Richard of Bordeaux becomes Richard II. He's 10 when he exceeds to the throne. Charles V is succeeded by his son, Charles VI, who is 11. And both of these young boys stand in the shadow of very, very imperious and ambitious uncles. So Richard II obviously has his uncle, John of Gaunt, but Charles VI has his uncle, who is Philip. And Philip is the young boy who had fought at the Battle of Poitiers by the side of his father, King John, who had been taken to London, who had lived there, who had then come back with his father after the Treaty of Bretigny, come back to France. And his father, John, as a reward for his courage at the Battle of Poitiers and for serving by his
黑太子的儿子理查，他出生在波尔多。因此波尔多的理查成为了理查二世。他登基时只有10岁。查理五世的王位则由他的儿子查理六世继承，当时他11岁。这两位年幼的国王都生活在极具权势和野心的叔父们的阴影之下。所以理查二世显然有他的叔父冈特的约翰，而查理六世则有他的叔父菲利普。菲利普就是当年曾随父亲约翰国王一起在普瓦捷战役中并肩作战的那个小男孩，他曾被带到伦敦并在那里生活过，后来在签订布勒丁尼条约后随父亲回到了法国。他的父亲约翰为了表彰他在普瓦捷战役中的勇敢以及在伦敦囚禁期间对他不离不弃的侍奉，将他封为勃艮第公爵。而这位菲利普就是后来被称为“勇敢的菲利普”的公爵，他也是勃艮第公爵家族的始祖，我们曾与巴特·范·洛一起做过一期关于勃艮第公爵的节目，讲的就是他们。那是我们最好的节目之一。所以如果你还没听过，那期节目其实是本期节目的续集。因此，如果你想了解勃艮第公爵们做了什么，他们在百年战争这一阶段的起源，以及他们在由亨利五世发起的、赢得了伟大阿金库尔战役的百年战争第二阶段中所扮演的关键角色。英国人再次像在爱德华三世统治时期那样，几乎准备好征服整个
side throughout his captivity in London, makes him the Duke of Burgundy. And Philip is the Duke who will come to be known as Philip the Bold and the father of the line of Dukes who are the theme of the episode that we did on the Dukes of Burgundy with Bart Van Loo. One of our best episodes. So if you haven't heard that, that episode is a kind of sequel to this episode. So if you want to know what the Dukes of Burgundy did, their origins in this stage of the Hundred Years' War, but they also play a key role in the second stage of the Hundred Years' War, which is initiated by Henry V, who wins the Great Battle of Agincourt. The English again, as they'd done under Edward III, seem almost poised to subdue the whole
在他被困伦敦期间始终陪伴在他身边，让他成为了兰苯第公爵。而菲利普就是后来被称为“苹果王”（注：原文为苹果/芇力，实际为芇力公爵”，他是那系公爵的父亲，这些公爵正是我们与巴特·范洛（Bart Van Loo）一起制作的关于兰苯第公爵皀目的主题。这是我们最好的节目之一。所以如果你还没听过，那期节目就像是本期节目的一种续集。所以，如果你想知道兰苯第公爵做了什么，以及他们在百年战争这个阶段的起源，同时他们也在百年战争的第二阶段中扮演了关键角色，该阶段由茨治五世发起，他赢得了阿基基基存战役。英国人再次像在爱华华三世所做的那样，似乎准备征服整个国家
of France, but they then lose their to subdue the whole of France, but they then lose their position because of the emergence of perhaps the most extraordinary figure, not just in the Hundred Years' War, but in the whole of French history, Joan of Arc. And hopefully that's a story that we'll come back to. We'll definitely come back to that story, Tom. But this is halftime. So, you know, it's England 8, France 8. Yeah. They've both retired to lick their wounds, be pepped up by the manager,
法国，但他们随后失去了地位，因为涌现出了或许是百年战争中、甚至是整个法国历史上最非凡的人物——圣女贞德。希望这是一个我们以后会回头再讲的故事。我们绝对会回回过头来讲这个故事的，汤姆.但现在这是中场休息。所以，你知道的，目前比分是英格兰8比8。是的。双方都退场去舔舐伤口，听教练打气，
and the second half remains to be played. So, Tom, that was, we sometimes do say this on The Rest Is History, but I think we can say it, or I can say it, with real feeling this time, because that was a genuine tour de force. A chevauchée. Four tremendous episodes as you pillaged your way across the fields of medieval history. So that's the first stage of the Hundred Years' War. Of course, the great mistake is to think of the Hundred Years' War as one thing, I suppose.
而下半场还有待进行。所以，汤姆，这真是——我们有时在《历史其余部分》中也会这么说，但我认为这一次我们可以、或者说我可以带着真挚的情感说出来，因为这绝对是一次真正的杰作。一场骑兵劫掠。四场精彩绝伦的节目，正如你在中世纪历史的原野上纵横驰骋、掠夺战果一样。这就是百年战争的第一阶段。当然，最大的误区是把百年战争看作是一件单一的事情，我想。
I mean, maybe the strategic context is always the same, but the characters are so different and there are such big hiatuses, aren't there? I mean, it's basically a 20, 30 year hiatus. Well, we've got Richard II and Henry IV, part one and two. Exactly. It's all to come. Still to come before Henry V.
我的意思是，也许战略背景总是一样的，但人物如此不同，而且其间存在着巨大的断层，对吧？我的意思是，这基本上是一个长达20、30年的断层。好吧，接下来我们还有理查二世和亨利四世（上下部）。没错。精彩还在后面。在亨利五世之前还有很多内容。
So that was wonderful. I knew nothing about the Hundred Years' War really before we started so I've learned an awful lot but the thing that I've most appreciated is you introducing me
所以这太美妙了。在开始之前，我对百年战争几乎一无所知，所以我学到了非常多的东西，但我最感激的是你把我
and by extension the listeners to the glories of Sir Nigel. So I think it would only be right to end with a final reading from Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's masterwork,
以及广大听众引向了奈杰尔爵士的辉煌世界。所以我想，以对阿瑟·柯南·道尔巨作的最后一次朗读来作为结束，再合适不过了。
a work compared with which the sign of four, the hour of the Baskervilles, a study in Scarlet, are as nothing. So these are the final lines of Tom Holland's favorite book, one of his favorite books when he was just a boy in Wiltshire. And you can imagine the young Tom listening to this and his heart stirring with pride. So here we go. The years pass. The old wheel turns and ever the thread runs out. The wise and the good, the noble and the brave. They come from the darkness and into the darkness they go. Whence, whither, and why, who may say? So lie the dead leaves, that they, and such as they, nourish forever that great old trunk of England, which still sheds forth another crop and another, each as strong and as fair as the last. The body may
一部与它相比，《四签名》、《巴斯克维尔的猎犬》、《血字的研究》都算不了什么的伟大作品。这就是汤姆·霍兰最喜欢的书、他在威尔特郡当小男孩时最喜欢的书之一的最后几句台词。你可以想象年轻的汤姆听着这段话时，心中涌起的那种自豪感。我们开始吧。岁月流逝。古老的车轮转动，线轴永远在流转。智者与善良者，高贵与勇敢者。他们从黑暗中走来，又步入黑暗之中。从何而来，去往何方，缘何如此，谁能说得清？枯叶飘落，它们以及像它们一样的人，永远滋养着英格兰那株古老的大树，大树不断绽放出新的一茬又一茬，每一茬都同上一茬一样强壮、美丽。肉体或许
lie in mouldering chancel or in crumbling vault with the rumour of noble lives. The record of valour and truth can never die, but lives on in the soul of the people. Our own work lies ready to our hands, and yet our strength may be the greater, and our faith the firmer, if we spare an hour from present toils to look back upon the women who were gentle and strong, or the men who loved honour more than life, on this green stage of England, where for a few short years we play our little part. Oh. Goodbye.
会腐朽在阴暗的圣坛或坍塌的墓穴中，伴随着高贵生命的传闻。但英勇与真理的记录永远不会消亡，而是活在人民的灵魂之中。我们自己的工作已然唾手可得，然而，如果我们能从眼前的劳碌中抽出一个小时，回望那些温柔而坚强的女性，或是那些将荣誉看得高于生命的男性，在这片英格兰的绿色舞台上，我们仅仅演出了短短几年各自的小角色，那么我们的力量可能会更强大，我们的信念也会更坚定。哦。再见。
Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家单集和提前...本期节目尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。